NATHAN ROGERS: Hi, everybody,
and thanks for coming.
My name is Nathan Rogers.
Today I have the pleasure of
introducing Porter Gale.
She's the former VP of Marketing
for Virgin America.
And her new book, "Your Network
is Your Net Worth" is
all about values-based
connections now
in the digital world.
So without further ado,
Ms. Porter Gale.
[APPLAUSE]
PORTER GALE: OK, perfect.
Thank you so much.
It's really great to
be at Google today.
Do I look familiar to anyone,
because I used to be over here
all the time because we did so
many partnerships with Google?
No?
Well, you know me.
So I was at Virgin America.
We did tons of partnership
with you guys.
Just to give you a little bit
of background on that, we
worked with Google Apps and Maps
and Wallet and Offers.
And so I do feel like I know
quite a few people here, and
it was great.
I was at the airline
for four years.
And ultimately, I decided
to leave.
I didn't want to be an airline
person forever.
I started to get very passionate
about technology.
And I had one of those
aha moments.
I'm not sure if you guys
have had these.
But I was sitting one day, and
I just was thinking, wow, my
life has gotten so
full and so rich.
Have you had that feeling where
you're like, wow, how
did this happen?
You've had it, right, where
things feel really good?
And I was reflecting, and I was
trying to think about why
is this happening?
What's going on?
And what happened was during
my time at Virgin, we were
pretty scrappy.
We didn't have tons of money.
And I talked to everybody
on airplanes.
I was constantly talking
to people.
So if you didn't have your
headphones on, forget it.
I would have been, where
are you from?
Tell me more about yourself?
My world started getting
bigger and bigger.
I kept meeting all these
fascinating people.
So there was one time I was on
the plane, and there was a
gentleman next to me.
And he started saying something
about the mood lighting.
He was like, the mood
lighting is so cool.
And I was like, yeah,
well, tell me more.
I work for the airline.
Turns out that he was building
a boat made out of recycled
bottles, and he was sailing
it from San Francisco to
Australia, a boat called "The
Plastiki." It was just this
fascinating story.
His name was David
de Rothschild.
So I said, can I bring my
daughter to come see the boat?
And he said, yes, of course.
No problem.
What happens next is that her
class starts studying the
environment.
So there's this ripple effect
of one conversation
impacting the next.
And so I started to become
fascinated by the spontaneity
of these random conversations.
So with that started happening,
another spontaneous
event happened.
I had met Tim Ferriss,
who is an author.
Have you guys heard
of Tim Ferriss?
You have? "4-Hour Work
Week"-- yeah.
I think he works more
than four hours, but
it's a great book.
So he had invited me to come
to one of his events.
And he said, why don't
you come and talk
about social media?
And I said, well, I'm getting
bored with that topic.
I've given that speech
about 50 times.
Let me do this new presentation
about three
degrees of separation and all
about the spontaneous
connecting, and that's what
I'm passionate about.
And he said, no problem.
So I go to this event
up in Napa.
I give this presentation
about the world
getting smaller and smaller.
So in the past, it's six
degrees of separation--
six degrees of Kevin Bacon.
Is anyone good at
that game here?
A couple of you.
I'm horrible at that game.
Six degrees of separation is
now down to four degrees of
separation or even three if
you have common interests.
And a lot of that is because of
companies like Google and
Twitter and Facebook--
that our connections
have reduced.
We've got more global
connecting.
It's much easier
to find people.
So I gave this presentation.
Lo and behold, lucky for
me, there was an
agent in the room.
And he said, I think
there's something
really interesting here.
You're talking about a
completely new way to network
and connect.
So we started brainstorming on
this idea, and we came up with
the concept for the book.
And what the book is all about
is that, in the past, a lot of
people thought of networking as
a very almost negative or a
have to methodology.
Any of you think of it as
schmoozey or negative?
One, two-- two, right?
Where even for me, when
I was in my 20s--
but I'm not going to tell
you how old I am.
But I know I'm way older than
you two, since we talked--
but it was really hard for me at
first to network and to go
to parties and have authentic
conversations with people.
And I've learned how to do it
over the years with all my
work experience.
So this kind of networking
that was uncomfortable--
and all of the sudden, I'm
thinking about when I was in
my 20s and it was an
uncomfortable feeling--
to now, what changed?
How come my ability to connect
is so much greater?
It's obviously age and,
it's confidence.
But it was more than that.
So I started looking at
networking and thinking about
it not as a transaction--
where a lot of people think
about it as going and giving
out your business cards,
figuring out how many people
are in your contact list--
but looking at it more as a
transformation and looking at
it more towards, how can I be
the best person that I can be?
So in a grand scheme, it's
not who you know.
It's who you're becoming
as a person, and
it's what you believe.
And it's what you're sharing
with other people.
So that's one premise
of the book, is that
it's not who you know.
It's who you're becoming
as a person.
So the whole first section of
the book is all about is there
anything that's holding
me back?
It could be something like
fear of public speaking.
You guys are probably
good at that.
I bet you do a lot of public
speaking at Google.
It could be anxiety about
being in crowds.
It could be anything like that
that keeps you back from
connecting.
So the first section of the book
is all about identifying
are there any barriers that
are holding me back.
Now, I share a lot of stories.
There is one story that is not
in the book, but I've written
a lot about it.
There's a gentleman named
Victor Cheng.
He is a very successful coach.
He does a lot of content, but he
happens to be an introvert.
He's very shy.
And when he started trying to
connect with people, it was
very hard for him because he
always felt like a phony.
So I worked with Victor.
He was actually at that
speech that I told you
about with Tim Ferriss.
And I said, well, what are the
three things that you're most
passionate about?
And start connecting with people
based on your passions.
So for Victor--
technology, entrepreneurship,
and family.
Those are the three
things that he's
most passionate about.
And I'll give you a structure
of how to do this.
And over the last two years,
when he would meet people, he
would start to connect with them
on the topics that he was
comfortable with.
And lo and behold,
it transformed
the way that he connected.
So giving you a little bit
more structure about this
idea, in the book I call
it the Funnel Test.
Now, I'm not sure if this is
true, but I believe that Apple
uses three core words when
they define their brand.
And so I talk a lot
about this.
I don't have it in the book,
because I don't want the Apple
people to come to me
and say it's wrong.
But the three words that I think
you'll agree our very
synonymous with Apple are
innovative, simple, and beautiful.
Everything that they do comes
out of that filter.
So after working with brands and
companies and brands like
Virgin America over the last
20 years, it's proven that
companies that have defined
positioning, a defined
mission, defined core
objectives--
like a road map-- are
more successful.
So how come as people we don't
have our road map?
We don't have our mission,
our objective?
So the Funnel Test in the book,
the first step of it is
figure out three
core passions.
And I might put someone
on the spot.
I won't do somebody
who's chewing--
as everybody starts taking
a bit of their lunch.
So-- three passions.
Step two of the Funnel
Test is tonality.
How do you want to be
perceived by others?
So an example of that--
Lady Gaga, bold, eccentric.
The tonality that I've picked--
and I hope that you
guys will find this one somewhat
symbolic of what I'm
trying to do--
so inspirational is the
tonality I have.
I would like to inspire
others.
But I also want to be inspired
myself, where I am constantly
learning and changing.
So step two is picking
your tonality.
You might want to be perceived
as intellectual.
as creative.
So now we have step one
is our three words.
Step two is a tonality.
Step three is defining, 15
words or less, what your
passion or your objective is.
Make sense?
OK, I see a couple people
thinking, hmm.
Any questions on that.?
No?
Anyone want to share what some
of their passions are?
NATHAN ROGERS: Those are
two of my passions.
PORTER GALE: OK, great.
So now Nathan, being that he
loves sports and kids and
volunteering, what happens when
you start connecting with
people based on those topics?
NATHAN ROGERS: I think people
warm up to you a lot quicker
because when you are genuine
and talking to them about
something you're passionate--
and especially if they have a
shared interest--
you really build a quick
relationship based on that.
PORTER GALE: That's
exactly right.
So he's not a plant.
I didn't give him money
to come sit here.
But when you start connecting
with people based on topics
that you're really passionate
about and that you're
knowledgeable about or care
about, you're going to have
more authentic connections.
So that's why one of the
reasons that it's very
important to figure out these
things and connect that way,
because in today's world, we're
no longer business life
and personal life.
It overlaps a lot.
We were talking earlier
that you come here.
You eat every meal here.
And then you go to the gym,
and then you play games.
And you're here probably
12 hours a day.
So I bet some of your
friendships are here, too.
So our business life and our
professional life, everything
is starting to overlap
in our new economy.
So really important to think
about how to have strong
relationships with the people
that we work with and the
people that we're spending time
with and to be efficient.
A lot of times, we're going to
have to do things that are
overlapping.
So I go hiking a lot with
girlfriends that I'm still
working on projects with because
it's an efficient way
for us to get things done.
So after the Funnel Test, what
I talk about in the book is
looking at do you have a support
system that actually
helps you achieve your goals
and fulfill your passions?
And if you don't, how
can you fill it in?
So of course, technology
is a really
important facet of this.
I talk a lot about technology in
the book, how it can be the
accelerator.
For example, I'm going to tell
you one story about how
communication has changed.
And you probably have thousands
of them here at
Google that you could tell.
But there is a military family
that I spoke with.
Vivian is the wife.
She lives outside of DC, and
her husband Mike has been
deployed six times in
the last 10 years.
And I said, well, how are you
guys staying connected?
Have you ever seen that
game where you put
a photo on a stick?
You know what I'm
talking about?
Like Mike on a stick, her
husband's got a little picture
on a stick, and she brings him
around-- a little popsicle.
So they've got two kids.
The kids, everywhere they go,
they bring their dad, his
photo on a stick.
They take pictures
on their iPhone.
And they constantly are sending
messages back and forth.
That has completely changed the
way that they can create a
sense of empathy, a sense of
connection and with technology
that wasn't here five
or six years ago.
You couldn't take your instant
digital photos.
You couldn't send it
over Facebook.
So that kind of connection is
changing the way we create
connections.
Now because you're in tech,
you've probably heard about
this already.
But there is research by a
gentleman named Steven Pinker
who has said that, in the
past, we had about 10
connections that were really
important to us.
Maybe it would be our immediate
family, maybe our neighbors.
Now we're up to 150.
So our circle of empathy and
everything that we're doing
has more ramifications
across our network.
Path--
obviously, you guys are
familiar with Path.
That's one of the reasons they
have a limit of 150, because
they want to try to keep
the close connections.
So knowing this, everything
that you're doing, your
actions, your behaviors, are
going to be amplified and
leaving a digital footprint and
impacting your network in
the future.
So again, this is another
big shift that we
didn't have in the past.
In the past, I think about
when I first got a job.
It wasn't that long ago, but
I do remember being at the
library researching and sending
out letters and making
phone calls.
There was not the ability to
connect with people by
LinkedIn or sending a
very well written
email to get the job.
Again, today things have
completely shifted in terms of
how we network, how we
have jobs, and how we
move through the world.
So another thing that I've
tried to point out in the
book, which I think is really
interesting, is that
innovation has changed over the
years and how we come to
breakthrough thinking.
There's two things that I
want you to think about.
The first one is that in the
past, things like the light
bulb, the car, a lot of
innovation was based on single
thought processes, single
innovations.
And now, true innovation comes
from collaboration.
It comes from co-creation.
It comes from people
coming together.
So your ability to network and
work in teams and to create
these strong relationships is
even that much more important
than it was in the past.
So I'm imagining here at
Google, I know you
guys have 20% time.
I've read about that before,
which sounds awesome.
But I'm imagining that a lot
of the great work is coming
out of team-based learning.
So that's another big shift
that's happening.
Another trend in networking,
obviously, is content creation.
But what I like to do is talk
about it on a bigger level
where the idea is or the
question to ask yourself is
are you a producer or
are you a consumer?
Now in our economy,
we need both.
We need people that are
buying and selling.
But if you are a producer--
or at least thinking every day,
what value am I bringing
to the table?
What value am I bringing
to my relationships?
Am I bringing ideas
to the table?
Am I bringing creativity
Similar to connecting on your
passions, if you're connecting
around ideas and thoughts,
products, all of those things,
if there's something in between
the relationship
that's here, you're going to
have stronger connections.
So I talk a lot about
how do you get
into a producer mindset?
A couple of things that
are important
with a producer mindset--
have any of you read "Little
Bets" by Peter Sims?
It's a really good book.
I would recommend it.
"Little Bets," basically, the
book, what it says is that
true miracles and breakthroughs,
usually when
they happen, we don't know about
it until it happens.
It's little steps and little
bets that we take to get us to
the breakthrough.
So think about that in
terms of networking.
There may be these relationships
that are
long-term relationships that
are going to be very, very
impactful for you, but you have
to keep working across a
series of steps.
And it may be multiple years.
So true innovation comes from
little steps, little bets,
collaboration, sharing your
values across your network,
and working together
in collaboration.
The creativity, that's a
very, very important
part of this process.
Another thing that I talk a lot
about is just how media
manipulation has changed
over the years.
And again, because you guys are
technology experts, you've
probably thought a
lot about this.
But it is easier than ever to
raise your profile around a
specific topic or subject.
So for example, when I left
Virgin America, I decided I
wanted to blog.
And it was very easy.
You can set up your own
blog, of course.
But then I thought, well, I'm
going to blog for "Ad Age."
That will position me as an
expert in the marketing space.
I'd like to blog for
"Huffington Post."
Anyone can blog these days.
And if you select the right
blogs and you select the right
content to put out there, it's
going to help you accelerate
your networking abilities.
So every time I wrote a piece
for "Ad Age," it probably
would get retweeted
about 500 times.
I'd get more contacts
asking me about
marketing or start-up gigs.
It's a great way to accelerate
your networking.
So in the book, there's also
lots of thoughts about
accelerating, how to connect
with more people, partnership
strategy, that type of thing.
Another thing that is core to my
philosophy on networking--
and it sounds like at Google
you guys already have this,
because Nathan was telling me
about some great programs
where you're doing educational
programs to help others learn
across the company, right?
You have something
like that, right?
NATHAN ROGERS: Absolutely.
PORTER GALE: And there's
a lot of volunteerism.
So you guys are already focused
on the "we." This is
critical because networking
today, if you're more focused
on giving and supporting others
and focusing on the we
instead of just the men, you're
going to have a much
more successful career path,
much more successful
networking.
So for example, I spoke
with George John.
He's a CEO of Rocket Fuel.
It's a media company that does
programmatic buying.
They've grown not as fast as you
guys, but they've grown to
about 200 people in the
last four years.
And I said to him, tell
me how it happened?
How did you get the growth?
And he tracked every single
connection back to his network.
His partners were through
his network.
His employees, most of his
employees were recruited
through his network.
His funding was through
his network.
Time and time again, he kept
turning back, and it was
through his network.
In a lot of situations these
were people that he had helped
over the years with
other things.
So what happens, when you make
an ask when you've been
helping someone for five years,
and then you come to
them and you say, I'd like
your help on x, it's much
easier for them to say yes.
So again, in the past, I do have
a hypothesis that people
would hoard their
contacts more.
It would be, I don't want
to share this with you.
I don't want to share
that with you.
And I want to make sure
that I get ahead.
And it was more of a climbing
the ladder mentality.
Now, the job market is more
of a horizontal in a
collaborative fashion.
Today's intern might be
tomorrow's CEO, right?
AUDIENCE: Hopefully one day.
PORTER GALE: Hopefully
one day?
Well maybe tomorrow.
You never know.
So the book talks a
lot about the we.
It talks about respecting people
regardless of age,
title, income, because the
world is shifting.
An example of that--
Dennis Crowley, who is the
CEO of Foursquare.
I interviewed him in the book.
I interviewed about 60 people.
Dennis--
actually Dodgeball
was acquired by
Google at one point.
Are you guys familiar
with this story--
because I see you nodding--
a little bit, maybe?
AUDIENCE: I don't know where the
story is going, but I know
about Dodgeball.
PORTER GALE: All right,
so Dodgeball
was acquired by Google.
Prior to that, Dennis was
working with three different
start-ups, and he
lost his job.
Oddly, when I met him,
it was in Tahoe.
And we were at a conference.
And he said, didn't
you use to work at
Kirshenbaum and Bond?--
which is an ad agency.
And I said, yeah.
And he said, well I was an
intern there when you were the
general manager.
And I'm like, oh my god.
And here he is, this CEO.
It's like, what happened?
I did something wrong.
He's the CEO, and I'm
doing whatever.
So he was an intern
while I was a GM.
He had these three jobs
at the start-ups
afterwards that he got fired.
He started Dodgeball.
Gets acquired by Google, and
then I don't know exactly what
happened there.
But it went flat.
So they stopped--
probably should not be talking
about Dodgeball,
but it's too late.
I'm already halfway in.
So then he ends up restarting
it himself as Foursquare.
And the pivot point that he went
through he describes as
one of the most growth-filled
periods in his life in that he
had all of this change that
was happening that he
wouldn't have done.
So pivot points are also
really important.
Pivot points can come in the
form of pink slips, job loss,
recessions.
Remember back in 2008?
I don't know if it happened
here at Google, but, oh my
god, half of my friends
lost their jobs.
And that's when a major shift
in terms of your networking,
your experience and your
abilities, all those things
can really move forward in
an exponential rate.
Today's intern can be
tomorrow's CEO--
really, really important
to think about.
One thing that is happening
here, and I think that it is
more rampant in Silicon Valley,
is that collaboration
and sharing--
and you guys can agree
or disagree--
I think it's actually happening
more here than it is
across the globe.
I talked to one VC who said that
software and tech, when
you are open about things and
you start sharing, you get
more feedback.
And then you have a
better product.
It's one idea about it.
But so people are sharing
more in this market.
So you can be the leaders in
this idea of networking and
connecting and sharing
and giving back.
You can be the ones that are
starting to have that trickle
out and creating great
positive change.
One of the last sections of the
book-- and then what I'm
hoping we'll do is
do a quick Q&A--
but the last section of
the book is called
Head, Heart or Wallet.
And obviously, head, heart,
or wallet, we all
need financial security.
We need to be able
to pay our bills.
We need to be able to feel
secure about that.
But this section of the book
really looks at how are you
valuing your life?
What are you looking at at the
end of the day in terms of
what's making you happy?
Is it the experiences
that you had?
Is it the relationships that
you've had over the years?
Again, time and time and time,
the people that I interviewed,
everybody from Dick the CEO of
Twitter to Malik to Brit
Moran, everybody started
talking about that.
It wasn't necessarily
the material goods.
It's the accomplishments.
It's the ideas.
It's the legacy.
So the book will bring you
through this thinking where
you're also thinking about, am I
connecting based on what I'm
trying to leave, in terms of the
world, leaving my imprint
and leaving as a legacy?
So your network is
your net worth.
What I hope that you'll think
about is that networking is
more of a lifestyle and a
process and that if you focus
on relationships rather than
just looking at money and
finances, that success,
happiness, productivity, all
of those things come
from relationships.
So I'm imagining that
a lot of times--
I've been in this place before,
too, where I think
about, am I investing in
the right company?
Am I getting the deal?
Am I getting the right job?
You get very focused on,
am I getting this,
this, this, and this?
Am I getting the right
stock options?
And I fully vested?
We start thinking a lot about
all these things that are more
financially-based.
If you focus on the
relationships, keeping them
strong, and you nurture the
relationships, you help other
people, my belief is that
everything else falls in line
and that you will have the
success, the productivity, and
the happiness.
So in closing, just to tell
you more about the book, I
worked on it for 18 months.
It was really amazing.
About 70% of it is story-based,
so it's
interviews with lots of
different people, both
personal and professional
stories.
I interviewed a young woman who
was battling leukemia who
talks about how connecting
helped her through that.
You've got the military
moms, entrepreneurs.
It also goes through a lot on
how to make an ask and how the
importance of storytelling in
today's world is really
important in how people connect
on emotions more than
they do on facts and figures.
Then there's about 30%
of the book that
is how-to and exercises.
So for people that are more
like me, who are more
analytical and they want a road
map, the exercises give
you a road map of how
to chart things out.
So with that, I want to thank
you guys for being here.
I see the book is on sale for
$10, which is the cheapest
I've ever seen it.
So I'm going to buy all of
them that you don't.
But it's an honor to be here.
I have such respect
for Google.
You guys were a great partner
at Virgin America.
We did amazing things with
you, so I always will be
grateful for that.
And I'd love to open it
up for questions.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
What I'd like to know is what
triggered you to leave Virgin
America and then decided
to write a book?
What's the journey about that?
PORTER GALE: Yeah.
I loved Virgin America.
I was there for four years.
I'll be honest, I was fully
vested and knew that I didn't
want to be an airline person
for the rest of my life.
It's a great business.
It's also a challenging one
in terms of the economics.
It's hard to describe what
it's like to have outside
influences that impact a
business as much as airlines.
The oil prices, swine flu,
everything you can imagine
impacts travel.
So at the end of the day, I just
decided I didn't want to
be an airline person forever.
And I felt like four
years was a good,
healthy amount of time.
But I'm still very
close with them.
A lot of the start-ups that I
advise now, actually, I'm
helping them do some
partnerships with Virgin.
But it was great.
I met Sir Richard.
Actually, there's one story
I'll share with you guys
that's really fun.
It's about the power of the ask
and going for things and
going for your dreams.
So there were these kids--
and I just did an event with
them last week-- but they're
from an underserved
area in LA.
They made a video.
They were up for a contest.
And they made a video, and
they sent it to me.
And it said, Sir Richard, will
you help us win this contest.
They needed votes.
And I had never asked him a
favor, because I just didn't
feel like that was
appropriate.
I would be like asking some of
the top people at Google to do
a favor for you.
You'd probably think
about that twice.
But the video was so compelling,
and the kids did
such a great job that
I sent it to him.
And I said, I know you're busy,
but if you could tweet
for the kids or go on uStream
or do something for them, I
would really appreciate it.
So that was around 10
o'clock at night.
The next day, about
2 o'clock in the
afternoon, my phone rings.
Porter, it's Richard.
And I was like, oh my god.
Is this a joke?
I thought it was one
of my friends.
And he said, I'm actually
in LA right now.
I'm at the Sunset Marquis.
I have about a half an hour.
If you want, you can bring
those kids over, and
I'll meet with them.
I'm like, oh my god.
I can't believe this.
So I call the woman who's the
mentor, and I said, Nancy, get
the biggest SUV you can because
Sir Richard will take
a meeting with the kids.
Gather as many as you can.
Now these kids are from a
low, low income area.
The point of the story here is
that, if the kids would have
ever asked anyone in their
world if they could have
scored a meeting with
Sir Richard, what
would the answer be?
Never in a million
years, right?
They didn't know that they were
two degrees of separation
away from him because I knew the
woman who was the mentor
of the class.
She gathers the kids
up in an SUV.
I think about six of them
went to the meeting.
And they videotaped the meeting,
so even though I
wasn't there, I got to see it.
And I have to be honest, it
still brings tears to my eyes.
But what's amazing about Sir
Richard is, first of all, he's
very down to earth.
He is very present.
When he's at a meeting,
he would be
giving you eye contact.
He would not be looking
at his cell phone.
He asked the kids, what
do you value?
What's holding you back from
being entrepreneurs?
What do you want to achieve
in your life?
And I can say with all
confidence that those 45
minutes changed the lives of
those kids, that they felt a
respect and an empowerment that
they probably had never
had before.
So that's the type of thing
that can happen with
connecting and the way
interaction happens today that
didn't in the past.
In the past, you wouldn't have
the tweet that you could send
to the president of a country
or to a basketball player.
We hear about it all the time,
kids sending something and
ending up with the NBA
player playing ball.
Technology has changed
how we connect.
So after that meeting with the
kids with Sir Richard, what
happened at their school?
Well, people heard that
Sir Richard was there.
And so then Steve Schimmel, he
was Googler number 13, he went
to the school and presented
to the kids.
Then the CEO of a skin
care company went.
Then Rob Minkoff, who
was the director of
"The Lion King," went.
So it was the ripple effect that
our actions in a network
can have so many
ramifications.
So your actions--
the kid who sends you the letter
that says, can I talk
on the phone?
Can I have five minutes
of your time?
That five minutes can change
somebody's life.
So that's what the book
is really about.
It's about helping.
It's about being authentic.
It's about having connections
that are really real.
They're not based on just
exchanging a business card and
having an egg roll at
some cocktail party.
It's about ideas and sharing
and doing things better for
the future.
So that's a very long answer to
your short question of why
I'm not at Virgin America
anymore, but that's my
favorite Virgin America story.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell us more
about how you maintain your
relationships?
Especially going from 10
relationships to 150 and going
from college to changing
workplaces or meeting people
on the plane, how do you
sustain those actively?
PORTER GALE: Yeah.
Well, the actively part is where
you have to think about
what are the core relationships
that are the
most important.
But I do keep a database of
all my relationships.
And some people use CardMunch.
I do.
I put everything in.
And so I find value in that.
Now I have a big email list.
But what I would say is
that there are ways
that are more efficient.
So now, I go to New
York a lot.
When I go to New York, I'll
invite all of my New York
friends, or 10 of them,
like, hey, let's
all meet for cocktails.
Doing group activities
can help.
I also call it being positively
and productive
where I'll overlay personal
and work things.
So the hiking example and having
a business meeting, I
advise one company
called ZOZI.
And they're all about
experience travel and adventure.
So whenever I meet with the
ZOZI guys, it's like, well
let's just go on a hike
while we're talking.
So looking at how to keep
being efficient.
The other thing that's really
important is all of those time
wasters that you have
in your life.
So I don't know how many emails
you get a day, but
think of all of the ones that
you could unsubscribe from,
those hundreds of emails.
So looking at all the
inefficiencies and keeping
your time as productive as
possible is really important.
The other thing is that I have
made really good contacts
through social media,
just because I'm
in the social space.
I have moved those from online
to offline by having Skype
coffees, meeting them
at a conference.
Oh are you going to be at
South by Southwest?
Let's meet up there.
So safety first, but looking
at, if it's an interesting
relationship, how do
you move it into an
offline one from online?
So those are things
to think about.
In terms of job contacts, I've
got to tell you, the annual
holiday card, a lot of people
don't do it anymore.
That's an amazing way to stay
in touch with people, and
people really love it, because
you don't get mail that often.
So little things like that--
a written birthday card,
all those little
things, a thank you note.
Amazing and it really
stands out.
So think about little things
you can do like that.
Also, when you meet people at
events or meetings, another
thing I like to do is, well, can
I follow up and send you
this article that I think you
might find of interest, that
kind of thing.
So look for how to keep it
sticky if you think it's a
good relationship.
AUDIENCE: So I see a lot of
parallels with Gary Vaynerchuk
whole "Crush It" and "Thank You
Economy." How would you
apply some of the same
principles if you're a scrappy
marketing budget start-up that
he uses, and what you would
say in building relationships
and whatnot?
PORTER GALE: Yeah,
I love Gary.
And by the way, we just did an
event at the Apple Store in
New York last week.
So we are in sync.
I think that his personality
versus mine is very different.
He's a New Jersey--
a lot bolder.
But I adore him.
Some of the principles that I
think work for start-ups--
let me give you an example
that's in the book.
So Melody, who's the
CEO of StyleSeat.
She used to be at Current TV.
And she knew in her heart that
she wanted to have a start-up.
She knew that she
had this idea.
It's like OpenTable except
for hair salons.
So that was her concept.
She was fearful about
how to do this.
And what she did was she
immersed herself in the tech
world by going to about two
conferences a day and
constantly getting in
and socializing with
people in the space.
Ultimately, what happened was
that once she had found a
partner and an engineer and she
decided to have an A-round
of funding, she already had a
network built up of people
that she respected and trusted
because she was setting her
vision on that.
So the people that funded her,
they also are co-founders of
Uber and all sorts
of other things.
But she had met them through
personal relationships.
So figuring out who are the
people that you want to meet,
how do you meet them in an
authentic way, so when it's
time to make the ask, the
relationships are existing.
It's always better to have the
people in your network when
you don't need them instead
of when you need them.
I'm a big fan of warm
introductions, too.
I think cold calling is
very hard these days.
So I always look for the
warm introduction.
There are trends in hiring that
more and more companies
are using LinkedIn to hire.
They're using internal
referrals to hire.
They're not going
to monster.com.
They don't use external
recruiters as much.
More and more is internal.
You probably all want to stay
at Google because you're at
the best place to work.
But hypothetically, your friend
who wants to be at a
different company, if you want
to be at a company--
let's say you want to get
to Virgin America--
the fastest way is to network
within that and figure out all
the people that you know
to get in there.
So those are some
of the things.
Immerse yourself in
the community.
And it's easier to find people
in the community now because
we've got online profiles.
We've got very specific
conferences.
And get smart.
Read and research as much as
you can about whatever
vertical you're in.
AUDIENCE: During the 18 months
of writing your book, which
one was your favorite
interview and why--
your most interesting
interview?
PORTER GALE: The most
interesting interview--
well, there's a couple
that come to mind.
I'm a big baseball fan, so Larry
Baer was really fun to
interview, who's the
CEO of the Giants.
And his story is pretty exciting
because he loved
baseball when he was 10 years
old, and all his life he
wanted to work in baseball.
And he shares a story about
when he was in college.
He called the owner of a
baseball team in Chicago and
was like, I want to do radio
show on your sports team and
closed the deal.
So then he started getting the
background in baseball.
And it's, again, another one of
those stories that if you
don't ask for it, you
don't know if you're
going to get it.
So he was really fun
to interview.
Michael Mina, the chef, who I
am now good friends with, he
was fun to interview, too.
And the reason his story moved
me so much was that he was
always passionate about
food, but his
parents are from Egypt.
He was born in Cairo.
And when he went to them and
said, I'm going to be a chef,
his dad was like, are
you kidding me?
You need to be a lawyer, a
doctor, or an engineer.
And so he made a deal with his
dad that he would go to
college, but he still kept
focusing on his passions.
Ultimately, what happened, after
about two years into
college, his dad realized that
Michael's passion for food was
not going away.
And so his dad said, I've
actually researched, and if
you're going to do it, you
need to do it right.
You need to go to the Culinary
Institute of America.
It's on the East Coast.
Let's see if we can
get you in.
So the dad came around.
And the way Michael
told that story, I
actually needed a tissue.
It was so powerful that his
dad came to a place, even
though there was a cultural
difference between what the
father believed was a good
career path for his son, but
Michael networked.
He proved himself, and he stayed
true to his passions.
And of course, now he
has 18 restaurants.
But he's another one--
he's in the book because
he flew on Virgin
America all the time.
And one of the things that I did
there was I knew who our
top 100 flyers were.
And so I had sent everybody
airplanes, those
little model airplanes.
So Michael received one
of those airplanes.
And I ran into him at
an event, and I
like, hi, I'm Porter.
I sent you that airplane.
And he's like, oh my god,
I love the airplane.
And every time he would fly--
he's got two boys.
The airplane is in his boys'
bedroom-- and he'd say, Dad's
going on Virgin America.
I'm going to Vegas,
and I'll be back.
So this airplane became symbolic
in their house.
So Michael and I became
very fast friends.
And he's now in the book,
and I also advise him.
So again, that's relationship
that I was saying thank you
for flying us, and you
never know where it's
going to end up.
And because of that, he's done
charity events and different
things that I've asked
him to do.
And I just had my book launch
party at his restaurant.
So you never know how a
relationship is going to unfold.
AUDIENCE: Can you elaborate a
little bit more on some of the
tactics or your secret tips when
you first meet someone?
For example, at networking
events or conferences, what
are some questions you would ask
and the technical level?
PORTER GALE: Yeah, that's
a great question.
So try to steer the topic to
things that you are interested
in and knowledgeable about.
Another tip is that if you don't
know the answer or you
don't know the topic,
be honest.
So my example with was, in the
book, I write about I had a
boyfriend in my 20s who
was a journalist.
And he was very smart, and
he had this book club.
And I remember thinking, I don't
know all the authors
they're reading.
And I was intimidated by that.
But instead of being
intimidated, now the right
response would be, oh, I don't
know about that author.
Tell me more.
Why are you interested?
So again, if there's
something that the
conversation comes up and--
people talk about pop culture
all the time.
Like, oh, I haven't
seen that movie.
Why do you like it?
Always try to probe
with questions.
And honesty is the
best policy.
And try to talk about stuff
that you care about.
The other thing is
that I'm more for
quality versus quantity.
So if you're going to a
conference, try to research
who's there and think about, who
are the three people that
I want to meet?
Who are the three people that
I want to focus in on?
And set your sights on doing
that, trying to just meet
those two or three people.
AUDIENCE: So now that you've
got this book written and
you've probably got a little
rest period, what's next?
PORTER GALE: What's next?
Well, I'm going to apply to
Google so that I can come here
and have lunch with you guys.
What's next?
Well, I advise about seven
companies right now, and so
that's been really interesting
to me.
And then I've got the book.
I do have another book that I've
already written about 70
pages of, but it's a humorous
memoir on dating and having a
midlife crisis.
So that's a completely
different book.
So I hope I get invited back
if I get that one published
because that will be the
stand-up comedian routine.
And then I've been creating
content with some friends, and
so I'm creating a lot
more content.
I also do classes on
creativeLive, if you guys have
heard of that platform.
It's an online educational
platform.
So I just did a three-day course
on building a brand
from scratch.
And I'm doing another one
coming up on networking.
But it's in that space
of online learning.
So that's been really
fun for me.
So I'm trying to take what I've
learned over the last 20
years and give it back
as much as can.
I am lucky.
I still get CMO calls
all the time.
So if the book bombs,
you'll see me
back as a CMO somewhere.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about this
producer versus consumer.
For me, I'm basically
a consumer.
Even though I think I have a
lot to offer, I always hold
back or whatever.
Do I want to share this?
Maybe from that--
to push myself towards the
producer side, can
you offer some tips?
PORTER GALE: That's
not uncommon.
A common theme of the 60 or so
people that I interviewed--
there are a lot of people
who are introverts.
And a good book to read about
being an introvert-- and I'm
not saying that you are
one-- but "Quiet" is
a really good book.
It just came out.
There's nothing wrong with
being an introvert.
What you have to do is
find ways to feel
comfortable about talking.
So already, you and
I chatted a little
bit about your career.
And you've been here
five years.
You're adding a lot of value
to the area that you're in.
I bet that you have a lot of
inspiring information that
many people would love
to hear about.
So what I would say is test
it out in small bits.
Mentoring is a really great
way to help people.
Start sharing in a way that is
comfortable to you, and you
might be surprised.
The example that I gave you of
Victor Cheng, he said that
it's really shifted completely
for him now that he's starting
to share and connect
with people.
As human beings, we need
people around us.
And there's tons of research
that if we have good
connections, we're going
to be happier.
We're going to be healthier.
or We're going to live longer.
Another thing you might want to
do is try finding a team.
I'd love mastermind groups.
I think that it can be a really,
really positive thing
where you get a group of maybe
five or six people where you
have shared goals, and you
meet once a month or once
every two months.
I do a mastermind group with
a bunch of women, and it's
really fun.
It's all tech women.
And we eat dinner
once a month.
And it's been huge for me.
I also am on an authors Facebook
group that I am on
all the time, and that's
been really supportive.
So look for the things that you
can join that are going to
give you some of that
support, too.
Yeah, I love mastermind
groups.
Well if there is something that
you want to ask or you
think about later, you can email
me, portergale@gmail.
Or we could do a
Google Hangout.
I have been doing
Google Hangouts.
Or my Twitter handle
is @portergale.
But it's been an honor.
I know that you guys are all
really busy and that you have
tons of stuff going on.
So thank you for making
the time.
And Nathan, thank you for
inviting me here today.
[APPLAUSE]
PORTER GALE: Thank you.